winter weather may have returned to
southern alberta but protesters remain
committed to their cause for two weeks
the blockade at the coots border
crossing has been mostly peaceful but
its impact on industry has been anything
but we estimate that the impact on that
is about 600 million dollars over the
last two weeks very few of the
protesters here in southern alberta are
commercial truckers in fact many of the
people we have spoken with work in
agriculture or oil and gas industries
that now say they are hurting because of
this blockade if manufacturers can't
provide the materials needed in oil and
gas then ultimately it's going to impact
our biggest sector which is the energy
industry it's days not weeks before we
start to see shutdowns
alberta's cattle industry is hurting too
eighty percent of beef produced here is
exported it's why the president of the
canadian cattlemen's association is
calling for the protest to end i believe
it's gone too far now it started to
disrupt trade it started to disrupt
commerce there's people that lost their
jobs because they would not take an
experimental vaccine so i just think
it's time to share the pain at the end
of the day we're talking profits
but i think profits
are not above freedom and so the protest
continues as the blockade at alberta's
busiest border crossing enters week
three heather urex west global news near
milk river alberta